hi Steve coffin here just gonna move
this guy yeah today I would like some
input you know I have these these
discussions I get some reaction from
people which I appreciate but I would
like some some feedback here ok I'm not
sure if I'm right about this and I would
like to have a discussion so I'm
starting the discussion and it's about
learning styles and I often hear people
say that some people are auditory or
oral au RAL learners some people are
visual learners
some people are kinetic meaning that
they have to do something they have to
move in which in order to learn and my
view and this is something that teachers
like to talk about because again it
makes their job and adds an element of I
think sophistication to to teaching you
know I believe the teaching is all about
the the enthusiasm that the teacher can
impart to the learner period and so I've
never really thought that this issue of
learning styles is very important I
happen to believe but I have no
scientific really proof of this but I
think we all learn the same way I think
that our brains more or less learn the
same way I think our brains learn by a
process of observing stimulus
experiencing things and gradually
forming rules recognizing certain
patterns that's why we can learn
languages I don't believe for a minute
as Chomsky said that we have a universal
grammar I think we have a universal
ability to recognize patterns in
anything that we learned and I think
that's pretty common to all people and
that the bigger differences have to do
with with our attitude with the extent
to which were connected to our
learn so getting back to the issue of
language learning I think that once we
get to a mode of learning where most of
the initiative is with the learner so if
the learner like it and I think the
differences come up more in terms what
we'd like to do rather than how the
brain learns some people like poetry
I don't like poetry a lot of teachers
like to teach poetry some people prefer
to listen I love listening I think
listening is is very effective for
language learning it's got its high
resonance to me the language the whole
field the rhythm the patterns stick
better when I listen a lot listening
also has the advantage that I can do it
while doing other things but some people
can't do that so I don't like to do that
some people like to read I also like to
read some people like to spend a lot of
time reviewing words and phrases in
various forms they have these spaced
repetition systems and they review their
words I don't like doing that so much
I'll do it to some extent it is
effective it's probably a good thing for
me to do I don't like doing it so I
don't do it I don't like being in a
group where we all stand up and sing
together dance together or play act
together or any of these kinds of class
participate participation exercise I
don't like being in a classroom where
I'm distracted by plenty other learners
3/4 of whom are not interested very much
in learning but some people like being
so there are likes and dislikes but I
don't really think there are differences
in learning well there are differences
in styles that are influenced by what we
like to do but not in terms of the kind
of learner we are that I can only learn
this way I don't believe that so I'm
sure I'll get a lot of criticism for
saying that but even if it is true even
if the distinction between a learning
style and what we like to do if that's
maybe there's not a big difference there
but the problem is is is removed once we
give the
more choice in what to do as long as
it's the teacher he says oh you have bu
er this kind of a learn right I'm gonna
divide my class into three different
groups the auditory learners the visual
learners and the kinetic learners and
I'll teach them all differently but I'm
gonna teach the poetry so the problem is
that you're trying to teach the poetry i
if language were taught using poetry I
would never learn a language never I
have no interest in poetry not in
English and not in any other language
I do like conversations with people I
should say that the the new Russian
podcast that we started with Emma and
Andre are tremendous casual excellent
sound quality very good conversation I
love it I listen to it I just I just
suck up the rhythm the feel the natural
sense of the land far preferable for
language very deep poetry and I have
tried with poetry but I don't like
butcher I just do that's great so if we
allow more freedom for the learner to
choose how the learner is gonna engage
with the language or listening some
people like watching movies I don't I
mean I like watching movies but I don't
think it's an effective way to learn the
language so if I'm motivated to learn to
acquire words I won't watch movies if
I'm motivated to relax and enjoy and get
stimulated and get turned on to the
language I'll watch movie it's fine so
that's I just like some feedback on that
how important do you think learning
styles are and since I've got some time
here before my video runs out I'll talk
about nother subject that's come up I've
been on this listserv with teachers
talking about how you know technology
can be introduced to the classroom and
there's a lot of talk about Twitter and
a lot of talk about using text messaging
and phones and the argument there is
that most kids don't like to even write
emails anymore because it takes too long
they like to send little text messages
back and forth and Twitter is great
because it's all in these little short
140 character messages and so that
Twitter is held up as a great
opportunity for collaboration with other
people and for people to express
themselves in the language they're
learning and I don't see it now I'm not
a teenager but my feeling with language
learning and it gets back to this
question of language styles and I'm
quite prepared to accept that other
people feel differently but when I'm in
language I start out with small snippets
four lines six lines 30 seconds and I
have to go to the one minute and then
the five minute and then the ten minute
and then the 20 minute and eventually to
a book if I'm always dealing with short
snippets I never really get going in the
language and and the first real book I
read in a language it's like climbing
Mount Everest it's a major achievement
and I think that we should encourage
people whether they're wanting to become
better at their own language or learning
another language to go to to spend more
time don't be distracted or you know
little messages coming in little Twitter
messages coming in sending little
messages so you write two or three
Twitter messages in Russian a day to
meet that's not as valuable as spending
an hour listening to very interesting
conversation in Russian so I still feel
Twitter as a distraction email or forums
but even there the you know yeah forums
are okay forums are okay and I must say
that I'm not normally inclined to write
in the language that I'm learning but
where we have our forums that link is
carrying on in Russian or whatever I'll
get on there that's motivates me to
write something and nowadays I can
because we have a spellchecker built
right in that really helps it on have to
worry about spelling mistakes and so
forth
so yeah writing I guess it's a good
thing but at least take a paragraph or
two and what I read I want to read the
longer when I get on you know if I read
a forum the one-liners in Roger I don't
even bother reading them I want to get a
meaty paragraph
and work my way through that so yeah
maybe I am saying that to our learning
styles so they're probably our learning
styles but I don't think the brain
learns fundamentally differently I think
they're people like different things
some people like poetry
some people like music some people learn
from you but I think if I liked learning
from music I probably could so all I'm
saying is I think the brain learns
essentially the same way but we have
different tastes and I think that the
where we are headed with with more
elearning or with more internet based
learning is allowing learners more
freedom to learn the way they like to
learn and so that it becomes less of an
issue for teachers to worry about it's
more a matter of making sure that there
is enough there for everybody's tastes
and enough support encouragement so that
what the learners go oh I take advantage
of this stuff so there you have it I
would have very much appreciate hearing
back thank you